do you feel like you are at times
participating in unnecessary drama for
someone of that's as rich as you are and
for someone who's been through as much
as you've been through well that's all a
part of perspective
listen like like you got someone tried
to kill you on Christmas obviously the
shooting that happened that we all know
about you know what I'm saying
I feel like
you're you're you're kind of like
this the court case got wrapped up and
you just kind of Dive Right into a whole
lot of [__] drama and I just feel
like
do you well I'm gonna tell you that
that's your perspective not really
thoroughly knowing me before music it
should happen to me that you see is just
highlighted now because I'm entertaining
and I got some Fame and a little bit of
celebrity but I really come from
the streets and trying to make it out of
that it was hard for me to get to even
this point of that point of you knowing
me I've been through way worse [__]
before I got to that point of you
knowing me right so now that you see
this and it's highlighted it just it's
blown up more but I haven't been through
as far as what I was where I'm coming
from I'm doing pretty good not I'm not
talking about financially I'm talking
about as far as things with people when
you one of those guys if I was like I've
always been like a popular person and
I've always worked like from high school
whatever there's been people that didn't
like me for certain reasons when I got
in the street I'm getting more money
than people I'm driving nice cars they
ain't like me for certain reasons
reasons and [__] happens in here and you
gotta protect yourself but at this point
saying that do I think I'm getting
unnecessary stuff it's all a matter of
perspective it's like it does there's um
there's [__] a full-time Champion
like Klay Thompson have to show his
rings to somebody somebody say clay
you're above that why are you doing that
it's all a matter of perspective you
feel what I'm saying there's Kobe the
the Black Mamba have to go off and play
Kyrie Irving for talking [__] like for
I'm a champ I don't gotta play you with
this Olympic [__] so because it's all a
matter of perspective right I don't I
think that with me I would be too I
would be above and I've never have
started any issues with people but
sometimes when people come to me and
again I don't want you or any viewers to
only look at or lock into the issues
that I do take on because mad issues
come across my desk and I [__] ignore
them right so if I ignore 20 issues or
people taking shots at me and this song
and trying to uh uh destroy my character
if I know that and I choose to you know
what [__] these 20 people they they
roach guts on the bottom of my shoe let
me deal with with these other four or
five people
and I think that's my that's That's My
Prerogative to do that you know what I'm
saying it's like uh [__] it and uh maybe
I'll deal with those other people later
maybe I won't but perspective is is
saying if you have a perspective it all
is about where you from your experiences
with life and whatever for sure look
Jay-Z was
top of the top he didn't have to go
waiting us he was already ahead of him
he didn't have to do many things that
he'd done he didn't have to do that
Chase he was ahead of nuns I'm from New
York I noticed he he got to the point he
said yeah now I'ma really step on his
neck that's when Nas started putting out
weak music you know I mean no
disrespecting knowledge but it wasn't
like it was right after nostradam and
then he came back with that still Matty
[__] like what the [__] you talking
about this is me so my thing is is like
you talked about like the new album and
how it's like one of your best bodies of
work you think it's your best body of
work it is my best body work because
I've been through
like New York City the album took my
whole life to make that right that it
made you without a deal more so major
what I did was album I always wanted to
make because it's a combination and a
combination of everybody I grew up
you're listening to him wanting to hear
him in rap and all my favorite rappers I
put Fat Joe in that [__] I had 50 Cent
right every push of teeth Fab like
whoever everybody was on this [__] Nori
Prodigy you know what I'm saying I made
that album because I had the ability and
access to people rayquan right Raekwon
one of my favorite rappers for sure you
feel me so that's that album New York
City was album that I did for the city
that can't that that'd be one of my
Greatest Albums Of Classic Albums to
people from New York City because I did
that for the city right I took my shine
and my highlight and I sacrificed for
the city I wasn't trying to appeal to
people everywhere else because I'm like
my city needs this I'm a sack I'm not
gonna jump on the south beat like
everybody else is doing just to try to
get on I'm a sacrifice and I'm Gonna
Stand ten toes down and rap for my city
but this album they hate I win this is
me going through my most tragic time in
life going through the lowest points in
life you know what I'm saying like like
total in the public eye and then
overcoming that and this [__] is like it
ain't just they hate I want is they hate
it we won anybody that overcame some
[__] if you woke up this morning and you
got some level of success in his people
hating on you and you still breathing
still carrying on is dead we won real
[__] and ain't nobody in hip-hop history
that could has gone through the [__]
that I went through lived survived and
then been able to put an album out with
it do you think that at times
the
spectacle of some of these beats you're
wrapped up in might take away from
people like diving into the album no
[__] I think it's the opposite [__] no I
I don't I'm gonna be honest I don't even
take the time like like I said I'm I'm
one of the most
um authentic
enroll
artists to where I don't pick and choose
my battles I don't say oh come on guys
this might be not politically correct
right now let's not do this like I take
the battles as they come if I have time
for it you know what I'm saying so like
I even think did I win has allowed
people to see how lyrical Troy Ave is I
mean real life lyrical like um um since
you [__] like writing letters here go
one dead hater I win I'm a boss you a
bum like the breakdown of that
this you know hip-hop
on that album I said since you [__]
like writing letters here goes one get a
pin I write this as a free man made paid
half a mill out the pen
I'm out of your league don't pretend
bowling on point like a pin I sat many
months you wrote To The Judge soon as
you walked in Mr Collins and his
Entourage me doing a lot of shootings a
recent one outside the New York City
Club pursue them and that was people
suing trying to take all our stack got
attempted murder cause I took the gun
from him and bust back these ain't no
made up raps I'm paraphrasing the facts
I'm the king of the underground he's
just an underground rat I rose up above
the road and stay trying to pull your
boy back with a cold show then code the
hand whoever reaching gets smacked URL
I'm a w i and Lambos and Bentleys where
I dwell it's a mansion for sale I bought
that you just bought to a cell a real
[__] lives on while a fake one dies in
jail
I took the actual
Court documented statement from ratstone
and put it in a song and made a lyrical
Mr Collins and his Entourage been doing
a lot of shooting it's not made up [__]
right that people do people make up
words bowling on point like a pin
everybody's no bars taking off
it's a mansion for sale talking about
where I dwell I bought that you just
bought to a cell like these are the
shits that people won't get or
understand so now when you got the light
on you and [__] oh oh you got more eyes
on you people like oh [__] I ain't no
chill that was that dope and I see it I
got a podcast called facto show I see it
in fact because now I put out old
records that I put out a year ago and
[__] yo this is crazy yo I put
it out a year ago you didn't see it then
right it's cool you wasn't paying
attention
you late to the party but come on in now
enjoy it we we always we showing love we
spreading love and destroying hey